is it possible to create
an ai system that you fall in love with
and it falls in love with you and you
have a romantic relationship with it or
a deep friendship let's say
i would hope that that is the design
criteria for any of these systems
if we cannot have
a
meaningful relationship with it then
it's still just a chunk of silicon so
then what is meaningful because um
back to sugar well sugar doesn't love
you back right so the computer has to
love you back and what does love mean
well in this context for me love i'm
going to take a page from ellen de baton
love means that it wants to help us
become the best version of ourselves
yes um
that's beautiful
that's a beautiful definition of love so
what
what role does love play in the human
condition at the individual level and at
the group level because you were kind of
saying that humans
we should really consider humans both
the individual and the group and the
societal level what's the role of love
in this whole thing we talked about sex
we talked about death thanks to the
bacteria they invented it
at which point did we invent love by the
way i mean is that is that also no i
think i think love is is the the start
of it all and the feelings of and this
gets this is sort of beyond uh just
you know romantic sensual whatever kind
of things but actually genuine love as
we have for another person love as it
would be used in a religious text right
i think that capacity to feel love
more than consciousness that is the
universal thing our feeling of love is
actually a sense of that generativity
when we can look at another person and
see that they can be something more than
than they are and more than just what we
you know a pigeonhole we might stick
them in we see i mean i think there's in
any religious text you'll find um
voiced some concept of this that you
should see the grace of god in the other
person right they're they're made in the
spirit of of what you know the love that
god feels for his creation or her
creation and so i think this thing is
actually the root of it so i would say
before i don't think
i don't think molecules of water feel
conscious of consciousness but there is
some proto-micro quantum
thing of love that's the generativity
when there's more energy than what they
need to maintain equilibrium
and that when you sum it all up is
something that leads to i mean
i had my mind blown one day as an
undergrad at the physics computer lab i
logged in and you know when you log into
bash for a long time there was a little
fortune that would come out and it said
man was created by water to carry itself
uphill
and i was logging in to work on some you
know problem set
and i logged in and i saw that and i
just said son of a [ __ ] you know i just
i logged out i went to the coffee shop
and i got a coffee and i sat there on
the quad like
you know
it's not wrong and yet wtf right
um so when you look at it that way it's
like yeah okay non-equilibrium physics
is a thing
um and so when we think about love when
we think about these kinds of things
um
i would say that in the modern day human
condition
there's a lot of talk about freedom and
individual liberty and rights and all
these things
but
that's a that's very hegelian it's very
kind of following from the western
philosophy
of of the the individual as sacrosanct
but
it's not really couched i think the the
right way because it should be how do we
maximize people's ability to love each
other to love themselves first to love
each other their responsibilities to the
previous generation to the future
generations
those are the kinds of things that
should be our design criteria right
those should be
what we start with
to then come up with the philosophies of
self and of rights and responsibilities
um but that that love being at the
center of it i think when we design
systems for cognition
um it should absolutely be built that
way i think if we simply focus on
efficiency
and productivity these kind of very uh
industrial era
you know all the things that marx had
issues with right those that's that's a
way to go and and really i think go off
the deep end in the wrong way
you